I'm here just to introduce the two
people who were up here on the stage
both of whom you most most likely know
and then to turn the microphone over to
them Byron August graduated summa [ __ ]
laude from Ezra Stiles college in 1989
majoring in economics and political
science he went on to earn an MPhil and
a dphil in economics from Oxford
University where he was a marshal
scholar he joined mckinsey & company in
Los Angeles in 1993 he's now a senior
partner at Mackenzie's Washington DC
office where he works primarily in the
fields of high technology information
and service to based businesses
education and educate and economic
development Byron also serves as
director of Mackenzie's social sector
office which works with institutions in
the private public and nonprofit sectors
worldwide on projects to improve
education and health outcomes economic
growth and opportunity and institutional
capacity for Social Innovation
previously Byron founded and led
Mackenzie's high tech services sector
and served on the global committees that
elect and evaluate new partners an
active writer and speaker on
globalization technology education and
economic strategies he's the author of
the economics of international payments
union and clearinghouses published in
1997 byron's co-founder and board
chairman of the Hope Street group a
nationwide nonpartisan volunteer
organization of professionals executives
and entrepreneurs developing and
promoting public policies to expand
economic opportunity he's a trustee of
the William and Flora Hewlett Foundation
has served on advisory boards of the
World Economic Forum and center for
american progress and he was appointed
by President Obama in 2010 to the White
House Council for community solutions he
was named successor trustee in 2011 and
as a former member of the Yale
University Council but as I said at the
start the most important feature is he's
a stallion
president richard levin needs no
introduction he's the frederick william
by nikki professor of economics and he's
been yields president since 1993 he
received his BA from Stanford University
in 1968 and then studied politics and
philosophy at Oxford University where he
where he earned a be lit degree he
received his PhD from Yale in 1974 and
joined the Yale faculty before becoming
president he chaired the Economics
Department here and served as dean of
Yale's Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences we're all as you know indebted
to president 11 for his work not only on
behalf of the wider world in the state
of Connecticut and of the city of New
Haven but also for his work on behalf of
the residential colleges including azra
styles it was thanks to his leadership
and the generosity of our donors that
this college received what can only be
called a total overhaul a renewal a real
renovation several years ago and I think
by now all of you have seen the the
fruits of that renovation work we
thanked him publicly and effusive Lee
when we formally reopened this College
rededication ceremonies in November of
2011 and we're very glad to have the
second opportunity to thank him yet
again for the work that went into this
renovation Thank You president Levin
you all know that President Levin has
announced that the 2012-2013 year will
be his last as president of the
University unless this community of
style Asians decides to try to persuade
him otherwise here in our dining hall
today he is today he's here today to
engage in conversation with Byron and
with all of us to share his thoughts on
the residential college system its past
present and future and the past present
and future of the University it's a real
privilege to host him here on this
historic occasion the first residential
college reunion a moment in which we can
stand back and reflect upon the
renovation of all 12 residential
colleges and to look forward to the
construction of two new residential
colleges in the coming year it's a time
to to recognize the university support
for Ezra Stiles and for other
distinguished if in some ways lesser
residential college communities on
campus Thank You president Levin for
being here
thanks Steve I've been fortunate enough
to have a chance to interact with
President 11 quite intensively here at
Yale in our work together in the Hewlett
Foundation in a number of context and
and getting an hour of his insights is a
real privilege I mean he's one of the
great minds honestly that I've
interacted with on a whole range of
topics so keeping that in mind I'm going
to try to organize this conversation to
get the most that we can out of
President Levin so we're going to talk
he and i were to talk for about a half
an hour and then about a half an hour of
your comments and we're going to try to
keep it moving pretty quickly have
questions quick and get as much time
over to to to Rick to hear from him so
in that spirit Rick the program says
this conversation is about looking
forward and we are going to look forward
but given the announcement that you're
going to be ending your illustrious
tenure as president of Yale I think it's
important to spend just a little bit of
time looking back and I'd love to know
what you were most proud of in your 19
years as president and what you think
your presidency will mean what people
will think about 25 years from now 50
years from now what was it all about
right well thanks that's a great
question to try to answer but before I
do let me just say it's wonderful to see
so many people here for this first-ever
residential college reunion its concept
that many people have talked about for
years and thanks to mark doll house
leadership at the aoa we're now and
Steve Penny's entrepreneurship and
wanting to be the first first out of the
gate we have we have this underway and
no doubt will be some follow-up survey
to find out how you've actually enjoyed
this but you know I I'm from the few
people i've spoken with on the way in
sounds like it's going very well i think
it's terrific and I just curious because
one of the things we conjectured was
that a residential college reunion might
attract significant number of people who
don't come normally to their five year
class reunion so how many of you have
not been to a class reunion for the past
ten years okay so actually more of you
have how many happened
well okay that's that's social science
conjecture was falsified okay so but
baby way thanks for being here it's
great so you know my presidency I think
it the themes have been pretty
conspicuous because partly because I
that was very self-conscious I there
were some major objectives when I first
became president of Yale that we focused
on really through the first decade but
most intensively in the first five years
and they were too to renovate the campus
really develop a systematic plan for
catching up on what was over two billion
dollars of deferred maintenance
including the 12 residential colleges
the stack tower of the Sterling library
the key facilities in the Payne Whitney
gym and every classroom building on
campus most of the science labs on
campus there was a tremendous amount of
work to do to the arts facilities and so
forth so we we systematically divided
the campus up into planning groups and
within the first three years really
developed plans for a kind of
comprehensive renovation of the the
campus and you know now five billion
dollars of investment later we can say
that we have effectively caught up we
have really well maintained and
beautifully renovated said of buildings
that a lot of new ones as well so I'd
say physical building would be one of
the hallmarks changing the game in New
Haven was another huge priority when I
take a look over the downtown was unsafe
there were very few residents in the
downtown it was abandoned by nine
o'clock at night it was a dangerous
place we'd had a murder on right on Hill
House Avenue in 1991 there was a we were
in the middle of a wave of massive
flight of middle-class people out to the
suburbs lots of vacants vacant housing
in the neighborhoods that faculty and
staff inhabited also lots of vacant
storefronts in the downtown we really
worked at building our bona fides with
commune
groups and with the political leaders in
New Haven to convince them that we were
credible partners and with and we did
some things early to arrest the
migration of people out of the out of
the town with our home buyer subsidy
within three or four years the mayor
convinced of our of our that we really
did have genuine interest in the
well-being of the city actually asked us
to redevelop the downtown and so an
unprecedented move we're a non-profit
took the lead in you know buying up a
very good chunk of the downtown
footprint becoming the largest
commercial landlord and the largest
commercial tax payer in New Haven um
we've done a I think a terrific job in
turning around what was a very bad story
and that partnership remains very strong
today and i think is sufficiently
institutionalized it will survive then
you know about five years in we started
to think more ambitiously about what the
key academic initiatives should be and
really for the past 15 years i would say
they've been two major themes and many
and many sub motifs but the major themes
have been to strengthen science at yale
yale has been historically incredibly
strong in the humanities and the arts
and we have great professional schools
across the arts and and environment and
in law and divinity but but the our
reputation and the sciences and
engineering somewhat lagged our
reputation in the in the softer
disciplines and i thought for a
university to be truly great in the 21st
century one needed to be in you know on
the short list of great scientific
institutions as well as in the other
areas and so we've invested considerably
in strengthening our faculties and in
rebuilding our facilities we the
financial crisis put a kind of pause on
the development our developments on
science hill but we've gotten partway
through that process but what is
striking is in the life sciences from
and including chemistry I would say our
science departments now stand and across
the medical school are now much better
than they than they ever have been
historically in a really really a
powerhouse and then finally a real
passion for me from the time of my
inauguration and I've commented on it in
my inaugural address is that where you
know Byron I have one professional
interest in common we both studied the
phenomenon of globalization and how it
has brought nations together and peoples
together and completely transform the
way we interact with the rest of the
world I felt very strongly that we
needed to become a much bigger player in
in the international arena to attract
more foreign students to Yale to make
them a more visible part of the Yale
College community if you went to Yale
before my time there were only two or
three percent of the class who were
international today it's ten percent it
makes a huge difference in the in the
life of our American students to have
classmates who come from all around the
world it immediately gives them an
opportunity in the in the sweets from
freshman year on to form close
relationships with people who see the
world differently you have different
values different perspective and and I
think that kind of cross-cultural
understanding is actually critical to
the future so we've set up all kinds of
International Programs fourteen hundred
kids a year go overseas ramiel college
mostly doing summers created a whole
matrix of interesting opportunities for
them and give financial aid to support
it so I would say those are the those
are sort of the big four there's been a
lot of other things that have been
important to me as well well in doing
that I mean you've made some pre big
moves including some quite recently for
example in science I think about the
west campus and I don't know how many
people in the room know about the the
purchase of the west campus and the work
that's going on there but I love you to
say a bit about what that means for
science at Yale and how you're thinking
about it well while we're in the midst
of this emphasis on science we we have
this serendipitous opportunity when when
the bear pharmaceutical company decided
to downsize its research operations and
put up for sale its campus in West Haven
Connecticut
seven miles from here right on i-95 and
we jumped at the opportunity it there
was a half a million square feet of
state-of-the-art science laboratory is a
huge amount of science equipment there
were other buildings from class a office
space a warehouse and manufacturing
plant all of which had space with great
potential for Yale activities and nobody
of course was in there were no bidders
who valued the science laboratories as
much as we did consequently we were able
to get a facility that would have cost
us sick at least six or seven hundred
million dollars to replicate plus a
hundred and thirty six acres of land for
109 million dollars and to boot they
threw in about 50 million dollars of
science equipment a lot of scientific
instruments a lot of which had been
crates that had never been opened so it
was literally this was the Yale's
louisiana purchase an incredible
opportunity and and so we've started
half a dozen scientific research
institutes there it's still in the
ramp-up phase we're way under occupied
at this point but we've hired some
really terrific people and we're using
it for interdisciplinary programs that
are that are that are centered on
applied science and medicine and and
that are I think held a great operate a
great opportunity for us to recruit new
people and to bring together people from
the Medical School Emma and from science
and engineering on the main campus to
work on common problems and cancer for
example is one of the institute systems
biology energies of energy sciences
these are these are going to be I think
terrific contributions we're using the
facility also for the Arts that the old
manufacturing plant turns out to be
perfect for the storage of our of the
collections that don't fit into the art
gallery of the British art center or the
Peabody Museum and we set up a centre
for conservation science out there so we
bring the conservation disciplines from
art objects to throw biological
collections to to Natural History
collections to library collections and
working together on conservation science
and digitization on the OU campus and
then to boot the nursing school has
decided to move there to occupy some of
the excellent office facilities that are
there and so that will bring up the
critical mass of people so it's it still
has its I'd say it's beyond the tipping
point now but it's still got a long way
to go to be fully developed and really
feel like part of Yale but it's great
potential opportunity for the future
Rick I wonder if just a couple of the
threads of what you've been talking
about you talked about the work on the
west campus in science as being
interdisciplinary and then even the work
not just among the sciences even but
between arts and the sciences as you
think about some of the
internationalisation initiatives that
jackson institute the big
interdisciplinary component to those
what is the relative role of
interdisciplinary work and studies
versus strengthening the disciplines and
how do you think about that going
forward cuz that's sort of a question
you know how to the heart of the work of
the university you know I think in place
like this you have to concentrate on
both and not either/or that is the
universities are largely evaluated by
the quality of their faculties and that
does trickle down after all to the
quality of their of their educational
programs and so maintaining the strength
and the traditional disciplines is
important and something we've been very
committed to but at the same time so
much of the innovation in in both
teaching and research comes at the
interaction of disciplines I'm looking
ATS the opinion thinking is one of the
leaders and founders of our
interdisciplinary program on ethnicity
race and migration which which is a
really novel approach to the question I
mean Yale didn't go the route of having
separate you know majors or
concentrations in in each and every sort
of ethnic group we have a long-standing
African American Studies program but we
didn't sort of complement that with four
other such programs instead this with
Steve and his colleagues conceived of a
program that would bring together social
scientists and humanists to think about
on a global scale
problems of ethnicity race and migration
and and subsumed under that you know
particular more particular studies of
the experience of Native Americans and
Hispanic Americans and so forth it's a
bit but that's just one example but it
gives you an idea this is that's a real
innovation nationally as well as at Yale
and there are many examples about the
Jackson Institute of global affairs is
another kind of example that brings
together Pope politics economics and
culture cultural studies together under
common rubric thing we started a new
major in global affairs that is rapidly
becoming one of the most popular real
college so Rick you're talking to sty
lesions here and our common experience
is as undergraduates you know a
residential college experience but Yale
is an enormously complex diverse
institution I mean it's got hundreds of
millions of dollars in in research
programs it's got a medical school with
an enormous and growing clinical
practice it's got graduate and
professional schools of tremendous
stature and ambition given all that
given that scope and complexity what is
the role of the residential college in
Yale today and in Yale tomorrow well if
Yale College remains as it does the core
of the University the residential
colleges are the core of Yale College so
the core of the core really it's an
incredibly important feature of
undergraduate education and life here as
you know and and and so we feel very
determined to maintain that very special
characteristic and one of the things
that makes Yale undergraduate education
so spectacular is that incredibly strong
sense of community now that would strong
sense of community would be very hard to
create in a school that you know had
sort of the typical musical chairs
dormitories situation I went to Stanford
as an undergraduate you know there are
120 housing options and you move around
each year to a different one so you know
you form friendship groups but you but
you don't have a it's it's not a school
that produces a very strong sense of
community it's a great place and you get
a great education
but it doesn't have what we have is that
strong identity the same group of people
that come in as your classmates and
college mates so that you have a cohort
just about it the margins of you know
who we would all know by name you know
100 120 people um that that really give
you a strong sense of identity and
actually create it's enough diversity
within the group that large that if you
decide two years into college that the
extracurriculars you've been doing up to
now are not the things that interest you
anymore you want to start something else
in some schools that's really hard to do
because there's a whole group of an in
crowd of people that are doing
journalism and you've been doing singing
groups or whatever you know here it's so
much easier because you have your
college mates in your class that we're
populating all these different groups so
people can switch around they can sample
they can experiment so I really think
the college is just played a
tremendously important rule and then
finally it gives an adult presence and
this is actually something that i think
we've improved in the last 20 years that
is the dedication I've made a real point
of appointing people to the master ships
as have the deans of Yale College and
pointing college Dean's to appoint
people that really care and that are
really going to put themselves in throw
themselves into the work not just you
know to host a few events but to really
be involved with the students and really
know them and really help them and
counsel them and be mentors and advisors
and role models and I think it just
works here it works frankly it works
you're better the other place that has
the same theoretical structure as
Harvard and I think this works better
for two reasons one the dedication of
the of the staff and the lives of the
students and second the fact that we
assign people randomly to colleges when
they come in so that each college is a
true microcosm of the whole rather than
allow selves into some sort of mix
self-selection after year one after
friendship groups have already formed
its it we really have it right I think
and with the renovations making the
physical facilities now the equal of the
social dimensions I think we really got
something great
that will be preserved for a long long
time yeah we've all you know most of us
have had a chance to look around styles
today and yesterday and and beyond the
campus and it's it's really an amazing
place a really vibrant place so it's
kind of hard to believe sitting here
that higher education in this country is
troubled at all and yet there's a lot of
conversation about the troubles in
higher education about the rising costs
you know more difficulty for people to
access higher education uneven quality
and challenge of online etc so how do
you how do you see the future of higher
education unfolding in this country so
that's a really important question and
there is a lot of public concern about
higher education today and I think it's
also often just missed characterizes the
sector really higher education is very
highly differentiated in the United
States it's not like some countries take
Germany where basically there's sort of
a kind of uniformity all of the schools
are kind of more or less at the same
level and get comparable funding largely
from the state the US has a you know a
kind of a tiered system we have the
elite private institutions Ivy League
and Stanford in Chicago and MIT and and
then a number of others in the next year
Duke and rice and places like that that
are that are basically supported from
tuition and private contributions then
you have this outstanding state
universities the flagship ones that you
see the deflection UC system Virginia in
Michigan Wisconsin North Carolina
excellent schools but then most states
have tears as well state colleges
community colleges that are two-year
schools and then there's a whole than
there's a whole set of liberal arts
colleges some of them well supported
some of them really marginal and and now
there are all these new players of
online or mixed online and
localized you know for-profit
institutions that are that are changing
the landscape each of these is there's a
different dynamic in each one of these
and if you really want to understand
what's going on you have to think if
they look a little more closely the by
and large the not-for-profit of you know
first to your research universities are
doing extremely well I mean the research
funding has held up our tuitions have
gone up yes and the costs have gone up
but with the generous financial aid that
we've been able to offer and the
priority that we and our peers have
given to financial aid you'd be
surprised to hear this the average price
paid by a Yale CI Yale parent has gone
down 1.1 percent per year during my
presidency that that is the say the
financial aid growth has has has been
faster than the growth of tuition it's
all inflation adjusted but but basically
a real decline of over twenty percent in
the cost of education for the average
Yale student which is since now almost
sixty percent of the students have some
financial aid with a really dramatic
thing now that's not true the real
problem with rising costs are the state
supported schools where their tuitions
have gone up in the last dozen years at
double the rate of the private sector
schools they started from a much lower
base but because of the pressures on
state governments which is actually a
reflection not just of the recession
which is added to the problem but is
actually a recession of rising health
effective rising health care costs what
you've seen is a massive shift in state
budgets from education to health care as
the principal expenditure and and you
know that's so when we say we have a
healthcare crisis the education crisis
and the public institutions is largely a
byproduct of the health
your crisis so I I don't think people
really understand this but it's I think
it's important to really know what's
going on I'll just say one more thing
the the innovations in online education
don't really threaten yale's they do
threaten some of these lower tier
marginal liberal arts colleges and they
threaten presumably some of the lower
tier public institutions especially
those that was costs have gone up
because you can get more you know now a
technical degree you know job
qualifications the things that have so
far worked best on online education are
things that are more vocationally
oriented and and or applied engineering
kind of courses and I think they do they
do have potentially positive impact of
for the whole sector for us you know
it's it going to be a long time before
online learning supplants the kind of
residential experience that we offer
which is still very unique and very
special and can't be thoroughly
replicated online on the other hand
technology provides all kinds of
interesting opportunities for us as well
as other as well as other places but I
mean where we have more and more
professors now who are have taped their
lectures you know we have 40 online
yield courses full full sets of
videotape courses we have a number of
professors now for asking their students
to watch the video tape and and before
they come to class and then they use the
class time to lead discussion among the
students so you actually get better
teaching as a consequence of this online
tool in those so Ricky I mean you paint
a very rosy picture for Yale even though
even as you have these you know big
structural challenges and and
transformations in the sector is there
anything you worry about for Yale I mean
amini Liz obviously a you know
tremendously strong position but as you
think you know 10 years ahead 20 years
ahead is there anything you think that
we all those of us who love you all need
to keep our eye on and really be alert
to what what do you see out there well
you know we have thrived over
essentially the first
16 of my 20 years because of a in part
because of a rising economic note I'd
strong financial markets growing
endowment jet the capacity of our alumni
and parents and friends to give Yale the
resources to do all this expansion and
renovation and program enhancement I
mean we've been very fortunate at a
strong economy as has enabled us to make
you know a lot more progress from
nineteen ninety three to two thousand
eight then you know we ever counted on
frankly so I'd say the biggest worry is
what's the future of the economy is it
are we going to get the kind of robust
economic growth and rising endowments
that and rising gifts that will support
the schools continue you know appetite
for improvement you know we have we're
strongly undergirded if there's not
another setback in the economy in terms
of maintaining our existing programs but
you know universities I think um campus
that were the cut it's the nature of the
beast is we can't really stand still for
too long Woody Allen has this wonderful
line in any Hall about relationships and
I would apply it to universities you
know universities are like a shark that
they have to keep moving or they die and
that's what we've been talking about
residential colleges and Yale and
universities in general but and that
will be your last comments you brought
up the US economy and the relationship
the relationship between the health of
universities like Yale and the US
economy I want to wrong that question
because besides being you know one of
the great university presidents of this
generation or any other generation
you're also distinguished economist you
remember of the President's Council on
science and technology I think a lot of
us here are concerned with the US
economy its future not just you know
where we are in terms of the recession
and the jobs numbers but the structural
underpinnings of the economy you
described a higher education sector
where the top institutions are doing
great and the other institutions the
middle and the bottom are really
struggling well you could say that about
many other sectors our economy including
our families and our communities in this
country so I would just love your your
view you know as you've thought about it
you know what is what might a comeback
plan for the US economy look like and
and what's what might Yale's will be in
that we're fellow economist that we've
actually talked about this a lot and I
think our views are pretty much aligned
you know we we watched the recovery by
not investing enough in job creation
quickly so that we've had this
protracted high unemployment some signs
that things yesterday's news is hopeful
but but still we've been we've been
we've had high unemployment and and and
many people under employed for an
awfully long time and that's it that's
you know that threatens a whole you know
millions of people who lose their
self-esteem and are going to have a
harder time coping so I've long been up
the view I mean starting and that you
can go back and check this there are
various economics panels throughout the
course of the recession that are on
YouTube that can some of our best people
in the Economics Department and I've
been involved moderating most of them
but the Yale wine on this is pretty
consistent we needed a very strong
stimulus and at the same time a grand
bargain on taxes and entitlement
programs so that out in the future we
can we can bring the budget back under
control but if you have to I mean my
view is you know nine and eleven and in
13 it's still the same prescription we
need to create some jobs and we can do
that productively in ways that will
benefit the long-term by by focusing
those jobs on infrastructure
both both in physical infrastructure and
in skill development and manpower
investments at though on the one hand on
the other we really do we have to face
the issues I mean taxes are way too low
given the scale of this economy they
were the lowest tax respective tax taxes
are lower share of GDP than any
developed country in the world and and
it just doesn't support the cost that we
have to bear as a society so the bargain
has to include reform of Social Security
and Medicare and at the same time yet
more tax revenue now that can be done by
without raising tax rates at the margin
because there's so many there's so many
deductions and loopholes in the tax code
that it actually is possible did if you
went for a very comprehensive tax reform
you could actually I think not get away
with lower marginal tax rates than you
have today or at least then you would
have with the bush tax cuts expire so I
think you know I think there's there's
rational opportunity here you know we
can sit here is economists we can design
things that would really work what's out
the obvious impediment is politics
politics okay well listen we're gonna I
want to get you into the conversation we
got two microphones and just to kind of
keep it moving we'd appreciate it if you
can come up to the microphones please do
identify your name and your your class
and ask your question feel free to come
on up if you by the way if you can't
come up to the microphone and you need
someone to bring it to you we're happy
to do that but if you can it would be
great well we'll get more questions in
and more answers and you just line up
the two mind if you sorry the two mics
are right up here yep go ahead hi Nicole
[ __ ] in class of nineteen ninety-four
as a staff member of Environmental
Defense Fund I've been very keen to see
the leadership that Yale University has
been taking in issues of sustainability
from everything from your speeches on
the need to address social science
issues and science issues and climate
change down to sustainability in
residential life with new innovative
meal plans and what not and I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about the areas in which Yale really has
taken leadership in these areas from
thought leadership to actual University
operations and where you see Yale taking
leadership in these areas in the future
well if I had talked about six themes
instead of four I would have mentioned
sustainability as well as that on the
next tier the next year of priorities
we've we really have decided as an
institution to try to model
sustainability practice it's the extent
we can and we can that we and we can do
that in an economically intelligent way
so so we committed in 2005 to reducing
our greenhouse gas emissions I
effectively forty-three percent from the
vent levels that that number was arrived
at by saying we want to be ten percent
below our 1990 levels by 2020 we're
we're not quite there I'm aware that we
we're maybe fifteen to eighteen percent
reduced in greenhouse gas emissions
since we started but we're continuing to
focus on it continue to affect
improvements we retrofitted windows and
switch and control panels and and you
know lighting and heating controls in a
lot of our buildings and all all of our
new buildings are certified to the leed
gold standard or above all the new
buildings so this is this is this
something that really energizes I think
our students they like the idea that
Yale is is trying to lead by example
we've up we've we've also introduced
sustainable food into the dining halls
and that has tremendous student up take
them if we have a there's a farm up on
edward street a few blocks from campus
that a lot of students are engaged in
and there's educational activities
around sustainable
sustainable food that I think they've
also gotten a lot of students keenly
interested it's important I think well
that students learn that we have finite
resources on this planet and we are in a
big mess in terms of abusing the ability
of the natural environment to support
our continued prosperity and development
and you know I believe we need to take
action and we're trying to show students
that that learning about these things
when they're young and changing their
habits or would be really a good thing
Thanks great thank you very much for
coming to talk to us today President 11
max Fisher lenhoff just graduated class
of 2012 as a chemistry major and I say
that specifically because my questions
about innovation and I'm currently
working in the chemical industry but my
question is the United States has been
seen recently historically we've been
great on innovation but recently the
competition has gotten fierce in the
international scene and I was wondering
if you could comment on how in the um
you know in the industrial sector in the
academic sector what can we do to stay
at the top in terms of innovation and to
I mean just going forward and yeah and
what would the role of what would yells
role be in in that vision well no you
know we were in an unusual situation
from the end of World War two till the
last decade of being um you know really
having our economy intact and strong of
having the an educational system that
encouraged in its best students a kind
of independent thinking and creativity
and and and the capacity to innovate our
system was much less rigid but or fluid
much more multidisciplinary and we
focused on a pedagogy at places like
Yale but also you know the whole top
tier in the u.s. education system of
educating people think for themselves
and not learn by
that that gave us a tremendous advantage
we also had you know the the most
accessible capital markets in the world
so that the whole venture capital sector
that made startups possible in a way
with very much more difficult in Europe
and Asia this is starting to change
because the rest of the world has
recognized that these key elements of
the formula which is which is education
and and and capital markets that allow
finance small businesses those things
are starting to spread to other places
and we are you know there's the
endowment of innate brain power is
pretty well distributed around the world
we don't have a monopoly on that we just
had natural advantages for I think from
our from our system that's being that's
being imitated in other places and we're
facing more competition there's no other
way to counter it except to continue to
invest in education and training and
infrastructure you know making sure we
that our universities have the best
equipment at state-of-the-art equipment
so our students can be trained on on you
know at the highest level and can take
that vote that knowledge out in the
industry and and to you know it's a sort
of support you know that the continue to
make sure that small start-up businesses
but also small and growing businesses
get access to the financing they need
I'm not pessimistic about this dimension
I mean even though that you know even
though there's been a lot of catch-up in
in Asia if you look at what happened in
Japan in around nineteen ninety they hit
a wall because they turned out they
could get their manufacturing quality
way up there production engineering but
they they didn't have anything like the
capacity to produce new products that
the US economy had
china china unless they can truly
reformed their educational system will
hit that wall too so so i think we still
we still have an edge dan band or class
of 67 question about the singapore
project which is i'm interested in what
your thoughts are as to its potential
pluses and potential minuses because
whenever there's something done in the
social science arena with people there
are both potential pluses and minuses
both for yale and for the Pacific Rim
which has been characterized in one
book's title as an area of three billion
new capitalists so if you could speak to
that for Yale and for the Pacific Rim
yeah all right will students be able
from other countries be able will the
Singapore campus allow a certain number
of students yeah other countries in the
region to go yeah so the idea is to set
up a to create it well let me say first
of all I think this is an incredibly
exciting opportunity that we that for
Yale to make a huge impact on higher
education and agent so it's going to
draw half of its students from outside
singapore half from inside and and and
we are recruiting throughout asia and
also in europe in the United States for
the first class that will come in 2013
the pluses from an Asian perspective are
showing that you know creating a school
that has the dimensions of an American
liberal arts education so of instead of
four years of specialized education what
we have which is two years of general
education and then some concentration in
one subject so you get multidisciplinary
perspective a critical pedagogy of
pedagogy of small classes that that
encourages students to think for
themselves and develop their own ideas
in the way that we do here and in a way
that is foreign to most Asian University
which rely much more on learning and
think about the transmission of content
rather than developing the capacity to
think so it's going to be American in
those respects it's also going to have
residential colleges and try to
replicate the kind of social environment
and community building that we have here
those are the sort of those are the ways
in which we're taking something to Asia
but then we're doing me on that because
we talk about introduce
interdisciplinarity a few minutes ago
this College will creates a laboratory
for educational innovation unlike no
other why because there are no vested
interests when we did a curriculum
reform here at Yale a decade ago it was
interesting and there were some good
things that happened but you know a lot
of this is turf warfare between
departments trying to protect their
interests and their access to students
we're starting from scratch we have no
departments in Singapore faculty are
hired for the call by the college
they're going to be organized into broad
divisions humanities social science and
natural science the courses are going to
cross disciplinary boundaries all the
course there'll be a common core that's
interdisciplinary in sort of literature
and the visual arts on the one hand
philosophy and political thought the
second one social institutions and
social sciences a third and natural
science is the fourth core courses
people take through their first year and
and the the amount of innovation that's
going on oh then the other feature is
east and west so so the students will
not read only about Western European
experience in their in their core
courses they will read side-by-side
classics of asian literature and and
Western literature and fuchsias and
Aristotle were contemporaries read them
side by side they seeing them
side-by-side you actually learn a lot
about you know for example to read the
politics next to the Anna little X you
see that there's a lot of commonality in
the way
these tooth great thinkers think about
citizenship men and obligations to the
polis but you also see that there's
tremendous differences in the role of
family plays and filial piety and
obligation in one culture and much less
more secondary role in another where the
focus is on the individual and so I
think we're going to I think we're on to
something really exciting I think
students will develop a extraordinary
way and I think well some of that
innovation will spill back to Yale in
New Haven and potential it does sound
exciting potential shoals this potential
shoal is you know you're in it you're in
a country where the political norms are
different from here and and you know
some of the ol faculty are very
concerned about that and it's a
legitimate worry and we tried to build
the safeguards that will that will make
this work I mean we've assured there
there are certain rules in Singapore
that we have been able to get waived for
our campus such as student organizations
will not have to register with the
government the student students can form
groups that have their membership that
are completing a chord with flour and
non-discrimination policies we practice
here so for example that we'll be able
to have LGBT groups at the campus will
be will be able to have political a
political union which today in Singapore
in universities and only the only
Singaporeans can be members we've gotten
that relaxed so we've worked a little
bit to get 38 more space for political
expression on our campus they're not you
know it'll be in you know it's a risk
there's a risk there but and we do have
you know if it doesn't go well we can
get out we've got it we've got an exit
clause as part of our deal so I think
it's going to be great actually thank
you for it
please and I'd also encourage others to
come up to the mic as we go please go
ahead hi David must class of 82 we're
here celebrating the 50th anniversary of
Ezra Stiles college and a physical
manifestation of its time and it's taken
perhaps 50 years to really reach its
apotheosis and thank you for all of your
investments in that but I wonder since
we're discussing the college life and
the future of the University about the
decision-making process that led to the
two new residential colleges and to some
extent there they're more referential to
the james gamble rogers campus than they
are to a sort of 21st century
architectural aesthetic so that was in
it so it was an interesting call to try
to decide what architectural style to
employ in the new colleges Yael Yael has
an interesting campus texture we have a
core of facilities very large core in
this kind of neo-gothic idiom and then
we also very well reflect the
architecture of the time so you've got
building's the you know like the binary
library and science the climb buildings
on science hill woman and the Louie Cohn
art museums that that essentially are
buildings that reflect the best of
contemporary architecture at the time
they were built I wouldn't say that
about the client buildings on science
but i would i would say that about I
would say that about the Louis Kahn
abilities about the buying a key about
ingalls rink and so forth and and these
buildings but um but we had you know a
number of projects in the pipeline back
in two thousand five six seven when we
were starting to think about this and
you know we consulted the community we
pulled students we thought about these
things um and uh you know in particular
we were more or less simultaneous
making a decision about what style to
use for the new colleges and also for
the new building for the School of
Management and you know interesting not
surprising the yale college students
very much wanted the neo-gothic style
used in the new colleges and stunningly
som students in a supposedly a modern
forward-looking business school they
wanted the yogic style also
overwhelmingly and they're in their new
building well we corporation we debated
this officers in the corporation and and
felt you know we-ell needs to do both
and there what of course this happened
before these buildings were renovated
and and styles and Morse and I think you
know it's possible a decision would have
been different afterward because I think
at the time there was a view that the
neo-gothic organization of these of
these you know sort of actually worked
better and and so use the traditional
style for the colleges and do something
you know contemporary make a build a
great contemporary building for us
around that was I mean that's pretty
much the way it went and III don't
really regret it Bob Stern has designed
for some really phenomenal buildings for
the new colleges alas the financial
crisis has meant that while we've now
fully developed the plans and we have
construction drawings ready to go we are
we don't have the funds yet so we're
still awaiting that you know anybody
wants to give us a couple of three
million dollars will be ready to move
thank you thanks um Emily sesh make how
much of the associate master here and so
I have the enviable job of being part of
this extraordinary community and it's
been wonderful to be part of the 50th
anniversary for a school I didn't go to
I didn't attend but which I have the
incredible privilege to work for but
it's impossible not to notice another
renovation that has taken place under
your leadership
up and I wanted to invite you to reflect
on it further one of the things that the
panelists from the early decades of
styles talked about was the
diversification of the student body in
the era of civil rights and the decision
to go coed and to hear that experience
and contrast it with the extraordinary
initiatives taken here at Yale to bring
first generation college students here
in large numbers to expand the
possibilities for financial aid
internationally as well as domestically
that has been the single best recruiting
tool for us hiring faculty here and for
me staying and being able to do my
scholarship and it's truly visible
within this dining hall which is of
course beautiful but when you see what
the residential college allows is it
creates a common community that allows
these groups and the of people from very
different backgrounds to really make
connections with each other and strong
relationships in a way that I haven't
seen it any of the other institutions
that I belong to and I wanted to thank
you publicly but also ask you to reflect
on the conversations that took place
around the decision to maintain that
financial aid commitment in the midst of
an economic crisis in which so many
pressing mandates were hitting this
university and yet you held firm in this
and have been a model for I know our
sister universities in maintaining this
and I wanted to ask you because we are
in a moment in which many public leaders
are saying perhaps four-year college is
not a right and not a necessity for our
young people and so you held firm in a
moment in which people were willing to
say this was not possible so I wanted to
thank you for that but also ask you to
tell us a little bit about those
conversations yeah thank you you know
it's interesting was it was it's so it's
become so much a part of the commitment
of this institution that that that is
that the sort of idea that we want to
make access to this place you know
possible for the most talented and them
and the people with the most potential
to contribute to society and that we
want to compose a class that contains
the people of that character from all
parts of the social spectrum
socio-economic spectrum and across races
and ethnicities I mean it as you say I
mean you characterized it beautifully I
mean it gives a vibrancy and the
vitality of this place that's just
extraordinary to have so many different
types of students here who share one
thing which is their brilliant their
creative their energetic and they are
all going to make great contributions to
the world so you know so it really was
last on the list of the you know when we
thought about where do we take money out
I mean in order to meet the the you know
the demands of a diminished endowment we
just III mean yes I'll take I'll take
credit for that decision but it was I've
got to tell you it wasn't much of an
argument because the corporation held to
that view as strongly as I do and the
officers and the deans as well so I
think and we end the fat and you know
the faculty you also believe so strongly
in this so it I think there was a
community I mean yes we could have tried
to take a lot of money out of financial
aid we could have had a much softer
landing in terms of other programs being
spared but you know what are we here for
if not to give opportunity to the very
best you know in our country around the
world
so we stuck to that commitment I i think
it's it's such a firm one that's not
really at risk thank you um I wanted to
start by saying I wanted to thank the
administration and everybody who put
this together I think it's a great idea
and I hope they're able to do it for
other residential colleges and I guess
my question is as you look at the
student body in an environment where
people are being increasingly pressured
to specialized early on one of the
tremendous benefits I thought of a Yale
education for me was the opportunity to
be a generalist to explore different
areas that I may never touch again but
contributed I think to an overall view
of the world that was generally
constructive it and I look at the kind
of next generation coming up and seeing
how encouraged they are too specialized
early on and that specialization
sometimes preclude them from some of the
more general educational opportunities
they might have and I guess the question
is how do you encourage in an
environment where it's increasingly
encouraged I think for people to
specialize early and kind of stay in
that field to broaden their horizons to
take classes that are outside of their
majors or their disciplines and to enjoy
some of the great opportunities that
they get educationally here that are
outside of their discipline so you make
me make an interesting point about
premature specialization but you know
actually in our student body I don't see
that happening much academically that is
the students we still you know we
require students that have done
languages and have done literature and
have done science so they I think by and
large we you know unlike universities in
other some other countries we do not get
prematurely tracked students
many of them academically but we do get
them way pro two I mean I think this is
a real problem in our society and it has
to do with the competitiveness of
institutions like Yale and our peers
there's a tremendous focus on
specializing kids that parents are
driving in order to get them to have
something distinctive about them so
instead of just good grades they've got
to be a great musician they've got to
have developed you've got to develop
some particular outside activity at a
single sport I mean in my day we played
three sports you know there were three
seasons I mean no more kids play one
sport you know kids kids over specialize
in something in order to get you know I
played three sports and debated on the
debate team you know I mean it was much
more common and today today kids they
focused an extra clear extracurricular
on something to try to show that they
excel it's it's a that's hard and I
don't know I'm actually not quite sure
how we can get the message out that we
actually are interested in students that
have more than one dimension and
that have multiple interests and we
certainly encourage them to take that up
here now it is true what happens is even
here as students students usually pick
out one or two things they really pursue
with great intensity rather than
sampling a lot but they do switch and
the things they do and the things they
do here that turn out to be their
passion aren't necessarily the things
they did in high school so they do
explore but then there's a sort of
Tennessee to try to be really good at
something you know I it's probably
overdone thank you well I hope you've
enjoyed this conversation with President
11 I certainly have I'm personally
taking away three big thoughts from this
conversation first of all that Yale the
university the college and our
residential colleges are in a position
of tremendous strength today probably
historic strength second that the
biggest threat to Yale as an institution
is that the other institutions that our
economy in our society depend on fail to
if those institutions were to fail to
solve the problems that that faced them
and face us and third that Yale is
contributing probably more than it ever
has to solving these problems in new
haven for our country and for the world
so president 11 thank you very much for
your insights today and for really the
amazing accomplishments of your historic
and transformative tenure here at Yale
thank you